[Music]
my name is Aviv I'm founder and CTO at
xfinder and at xfind we're uh changing
the way companies utilize knowledge and
insights in what we call using what we
call our contextual intelligence engine
so essentially what we do is we connect
to all of our customers knowledge and
this can be anything from slack channels
to knowledge bases and crms we process
all that data and we feed it into
architectural and intelligence engine
and this allows us to bring our
customers accurate information in
context to whatever it is they're doing
uh with analytics and insights without
them having to tag it or search for it
but but supporting all those knowledge
sources created a problem for us
because uh instead of having our data
science team focus on our core
algorithms and models they have to focus
on transforming that data for each new
customer and that all those new
customers they always use those data
sources a bit differently
and our data science team had to
transform that data into a single format
that we can use so that we can feed into
our system
so naturally we look for a solution
something that will enable our
non-coders or analysts to uh create
modify and uh run those data processing
pipelines all by themselves
independently of the data science team
uh so uh they can be much more dependent
and on their own and not bother our data
science team with uh every new customer
that comes and needs to be onboarded uh
so what we'll what I'm going to present
here in the next couple of minutes is
just our solution
and uh We've made it much a lot simpler
so it'll be much clearer for this
presentation
uh so let's say we have three data sets
sorry about that uh and we want to use
them uh in our um we want to feed it
into our database uh so we need to
transform it
uh in those databases they come a bit
different I mean they format it a bit
differently we have uh fields that have
HTML tags in them and some of the data
sets others don't and of course we want
to transform them into a single format
that we can use
uh and uh that's classic ETL right but
again we want to make sure that our
non-coders are able to uh run that by
themselves and and uh all do all this uh
pipeline by themselves without having to
disturb our data science team
so what we did is we created a couple of
files and we took all our data
processing data processing functions and
we placed them in those files so they
can easily be invoked for example here
we have the clean HTML function that
just removes HTML tags we've got a
format name format tags
and then we Define the yaml file
as a mapping from Old Fields to new
fields and we added the functions uh
list that we can just invoke functions
one after another and change that
change the field to whatever we need for
our database structure
so for example we had the if we had a
text field and in some data sets it came
with for HTML we could just remove it by
invoking the clean HTML function
or if we want to create a new field with
entities from that text field all we
have to do is write those couple of
lines in our yaml file invoke our
extract entities function and that was
about it
uh so essentially what we did was we
enabled our analyst and our non-coders
to create those yaml files easily and
run our data processing functions for
all new customers without having to uh
bother our data science team and that
saved us a lot of time and allowed our
data science team to focus on what's
important for the company because we're
a small company and that's time matters
and um
and so so that's exactly what we did we
create we allowed we made that happen uh
and I know this is a bit abstract and
quick so I have a link to our simple
project on GitHub which can be and this
use this can be extended and modified
infinitely and we have we're using it
for a lot of things
uh so thank you for listening uh here's
a link
and if you're interested in what we're
doing at xfinda feel free to go to our
website and check us out thank you
[Applause]
[Music]